[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le retrait
des forces françaises du mali s'il
annonce officielle n'interviendra que
dans quelques heures le sort de barkan
semble scellé macron a réuni à l'elysée
ses homologues présidents du sahel pour
en décider nous irons à bamako connaître
les réactions des populations et nous
analyserons les conséquences militaires
de ce retrait
polhenri sandaogo damiba officiellement
investi président du burkina faso
trois semaines après avoir renversé
l'ancien président élu roch marc
christian kaboré nous irons sur place
dans ce journal
l'ethiopie à nouveau victime d'une
terrible sécheresse les nations unies
estiment à 13 millions le nombre de
personnes menacées par la faim dans
toute la corne de l'afrique reportage à
suivre dans la région de somalie
particulièrement touchée où les animaux
meurent à cause du manque d'eau et de
pâturage
ce n'est plus qu'une question d'heures
le président emmanuel macron qui a reçu
ses homologues du sahel à l'elysée
devrait annoncer le retrait de la france
du mali un retrait qui intervient après
neuf ans de présence des forces
tricolores à la demande des autorités
maliennes pour lutter contre la menace
des indices aujourd'hui les avis sont
partagés si à bamako la population
soutenant la junte est plutôt favorable
au départ des militaires français
tendresse lui pays les avis sont plus
mitigés comme nous l'expliquent notre
correspondante anne-flore les spirou à
bamako les maliens sont nombreux à
demander le départ de la france au
profit de nouveaux partenaires comme la
russie la chine ou encore la turquie la
plupart des maliens salue également la
montée en puissance ces dernières
semaines de l'armée malienne une armée
qui affirme avoir permis le retour de la
sécurité dans certaines localités du
centre du pays épicentre du conflit au
mali
morgan a montré ses limites on dit
vraiment que babel barca et merci à nos
autorités qui a vraiment écouté le
peuple qui ont compris que le pull de
vraiment pas de berkane se sortir du
toit en plus de son travail avec
d'autres partenaires la russie est déjà
là donc pour vous dire qu'on avait
besoin d'information est aujourd'hui la
région dans les informations des
satellites et autres mais sur le terrain
au nord du pays la question de l'après
du vide laissé par barkan fait débat
auprès des populations qui sont l impact
et au quotidien par le conflit sur un
territoire dont les deux tiers sont
aujourd'hui au mans des groupes
djihadistes
la responsabilité dans les réseaux sur
les mains sont partagés les parties à
l'accord particulièrement du
gouvernement et les mouvements internes
devaient s'entendre c'est le mécanisme
de redéploiement de face qui boivent à
sceller ces critères la place des
barricades ne vit que ça n'avait pas
fonctionné
cela contredit beaucoup à l'enlisement
d'opérations tracasser les trains la
grande question est ce que c'est qui
demande son départ
en toute responsabilité y compris nous
avons déjà un plan de l'alternative
alors le départ de barkan permettra-t-il
la mise en place d'une armée reconstitué
est composé de tous les fils du pays
dont les anciens combattants comme le
prévoit l'accord de paix d'alger
permettra-t-il de façon officielle
l'ouverture d'un dialogue avec les
djihadistes et quel sera l'impact sur
les partenaires militaires et les ong
qui oeuvrent sur le terrain et
bénéficier jusqu'à lors de l'appui de la
force française en cas de problème à
l'aube des annonces de la france les
incertitudes restent nombreuses
vous l'avez entendu notre correspondante
sur place beaucoup de questions
soulèvent cette fin d'opération de
barkan que deviendront les 2400 soldats
français déployés au mali qui luttent
contre les dialyses depuis 2014 comment
va se traduire leur déploiement des
forces françaises dans le sahel a priori
ce serait niger qui deviendrait l'allié
privilégié éléments de réponse avec dame
utiles vers
le départ de l'armée française du mali
véritable casse tête logistique aux
implications multiples il faudra d'abord
vider les trois bases installées dans le
pays gao gossier ménaka soit 2400
soldats français de l'opération barkan
qui participent depuis 2014 à la traque
des groupes jihadistes dans le sahel il
ne devrait a priori pas rejoindre les
2400 autres militaires stationnés dans
les pays voisins le golfe de guinée
autre front de la lutte anti terroriste
pourrait être un point de chute
potentiels au delà de barkan le retrait
français qui s'étalera sur une période
de six mois à un an va également
entraîner la fin de la force takouba
créé il ya moins de deux ans cette task
force regroupe 800 membres des forces
spéciales dont une moitié de français
très autres pays européens y ont
participé la suède s'est retiré en
janvier dernier suivie du danemark dont
la junte malienne a exigé le départ
autre conséquence de la décision de
paris l'évacuation des contingents
européens de la minus ma soit environ
10% des forces de cette mission des
nations unies au mali ainsi que celle
des dizaines de membres de l'utm la
mission de formation de l'union
européenne au mali malgré le retrait de
toutes ses troupes la france va
provisoirement continuer d'apporter un
soutien aérien et médical à la minus
mahéo forces armées maliennes enfin les
unités des forces spéciales sabres basé
au burkina faso seront toujours
susceptible d'intervenir de manière
ciblée du côté malien de la frontière
il ya trois semaines il prenait le
pouvoir par un coup d'état en renversant
l'unique président élu du prix burkina
faso rock marc christian kaboré
aujourd'hui le lieutenant-colonel paul
henri sandaogo damiba et président chef
de l'état et chef des armées et il a
prêté serment et juré devant le peuple
burkinabè de préserver de respecter et
de faire respecter tout en défendant la
constitution khalid aussi la cérémonie
d'investiture s'est tenue dans une
petite salle du conseil constitutionnel
dans laquelle seule l'équipe de
communication de la présidence avait
accès pour la couverture médiatique la
presse nationale et internationale n'ont
pas eu l'autorisation d'y assister et
c'est vêtu de son habituelle très
militaires bérets rouges avec une
écharpe aux couleurs du drapeau
burkinabè que paul-henri sandaogo danube
à 41 ans a prêté serment pour devenir le
dixième chef d'état burkinabè depuis
l'indépendance du pays dans son discours
il a qualifié la restauration de
l'intégrité du territoire comme priorité
absolue mais dit également vouloir
lutter contre la corruption véritable
serpent de mer dans le pays depuis
plusieurs décennies
du côté partenaires internationaux dans
la lutte contre le djihadisme et alors
que la force barkan devrait quitter le
mali incessamment sous peu d'aucuns se
demandent quelle sera la position du
burkina faso et du désormais président
damiba sur la coopération militaire avec
la france dans son discours il a déclaré
en ces moments difficiles notre pays n'a
pas été abandonné par ses partenaires
c'est l'occasion pour moi de remercier
la communauté internationale pour tous
les efforts consentis pour accompagner
le burkina faso il a également ajouté le
burkina faso réitère sa disponibilité à
travailler en toute souveraineté avec
tous les partenaires dans le respect
mutuel alors que la durée de son mandat
sera déterminé par la charte de la
transition selon le président du conseil
constitutionnel la prochaine étape pour
le président damiba sera justement de
composer un gouvernement de transition
pour conduire les affaires courantes du
burkina faso mais surtout pour remplir
son objectif prioritaire est ce pourquoi
il avait mené un coup d'état contre l'ex
président kaboré la lutte contre
l'insécurité et donc la restauration de
l'intégrité du territoire national
en somalie les djihadistes shebab ont
lancé plusieurs attaques simultanées sur
des commissariats à mogadiscio le bilan
fait état d'au moins deux morts et d'une
vingtaine de blessés
ces attaques ont lieu alors que le pays
est plongé dans une profonde crise
politique qui oppose le premier ministre
président ce dernier dont le mandat a
expiré l'année dernière sans qu'il ait
réussi à organiser des élections laurent
imbert ses chiens
encore sonné par l'explosion les
habitants du quartier de karrada à
mogadiscio r parmi les décombres de leur
maison il ne reste que quelques débris
éparpillés cible au collatéral de la
tacc du commissariat voisin par des
militants shebab dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi
une explosion a retenti dans le
commissariat et nous a réveillés puis
des coups de feu ont éclaté
comme vous pouvez le voir
notre maison et les maisons voisines ont
été gravement endommagés
c'était une opération d'envergure menée
par les djihadistes qui ont
simultanément ciblé plusieurs
commissariats et checkpoint de la
capitale la série d' attaque a été
revendiquée par le groupe islamiste al
shebab qui mènent depuis des années une
insurrection contre le pouvoir ce malien
ces derniers mois les attaques visant
des militaires des diplomates et des
dignitaires étrangers ont gagné en
intensité
faisant craindre l'éclosion d'une
nouvelle crise sécuritaire en pleine
période électorale
les somaliens doivent se rendre aux
urnes à la fin du mois de février pour
élire leur prochain président en
ethiopie ce sont les conditions
climatiques inquiètent la corne de
l'afrique fait face à la pire sécheresse
enregistrée depuis 30 ans les nations
unies estiment que 13 millions de
personnes sont menacées par la faim plus
d'un million et demi d'animaux seraient
morts dans la région à cause d'un manque
d'eau et de pâturage l'ethiopie fait
partie des pays les plus touchés
reportage en régions somali de maria
guerre ce n'est qu'au losc
faute de trouver un lieu de pâturage les
animaux de sept hommes sont morts de
faim dans le sud de la région somali il
n'a pas plu depuis neuf mois les
communautés pastorales qui vivent de
leur bétail sont particulièrement
touchés
la sécheresse a impacté mon propos
j'avais 300 animaux et 200 sont morts
ils ont été affectées par le manque
d'eau et le manque de nourriture cela a
rendu mes animaux très faible
la majorité des puits sont asséchées ici
seule une réserve d'eau approvisionne un
rayon de 10 km mais cette source est
sale et transmet des maladies et
les insectes et la saleté peuvent entrer
les prédateurs les animaux sauvages même
les oiseaux il n'y a pas de couvercle de
protection la condition des animaux et
du secondaire maintenant nous inquiétons
pour notre vie pour la vie de nos
enfants
d'ici mi mars 6,8 millions de personnes
auront besoin d'une aide humanitaire
d'urgence
selon l'unicef la sécheresse a fait
augmenter de 20% le nombre d'enfants mal
nourris dans la région
cette mère adolescente vient d'arriver
dans cet hôpital avec sa fille de deux
ans
en raison de la situation actuelle les
enfants n'ont pas accès à de l'eau
propre à de la nourriture nutritive pour
cette raison les enfants donc souffrir
de diarrhée déshydratation des
vomissements qui peuvent aussi développé
de la fièvre
face à la gravité de la situation des
milliers de personnes ont fui vers le
nord de la région dans l'espoir de
trouver de la nourriture pour eux et
pour leurs animaux ibrahim abdi a laissé
sa femme il derrière lui et marcher
pendant quinze jours avec ses buts
parler
ceux qui ont survécu à la sécheresse
sont malades le problème principal
maintenant ce sont les maladies animales
ces maladies devraient être traités au
vu de la gravité de la situation ma
femme m'appelle et me demandent de
revenir pour que nous puissions mourir
au moment de
la prochaine saison des pluies n'est pas
prévue avant le mois d'avril les
organisations se prépare au pire mais
manquent de moyens pour répondre aux
besoins grandissants
le gouvernement béninois en guerre
contre les centres de santé clandestins
depuis le mois de janvier une vingtaine
ou moins ont été fermées dans tout le
pays mais plus grave encore il existe
aujourd'hui tout un réseau d' aides
soignants qui se ferait passer pour des
médecins reportage d'emmanuel sug
pour échapper à la traque les domiciles
des faux médecins ne sont jamais
repérable ni plaque ni signe distinctif
ils consultent discrètement ou se
déplace à domicile dans les quartiers
populaires de porto novo au bénin
c'est du bouche à oreille on te dit
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est venu me
soigner à la maison il est très bon
donne-moi son numéro et ainsi de suite
on l'appelle il nous indique chez lui où
il vient là où on vit cet homme souhaite
parler de manière anonyme il soigne
clandestinement ses patients depuis sept
ans en réalité les aides soignants
formés sur le tas dans une clinique
privée
ce que je connais dans le domaine de la
santé ce n'est pas petit parce que tous
les jours je suis confronté à des
situations quand je suis à la clinique
je regarde la manière dont le médecin
fait et quand je suis dehors je procède
de la même manière après les soins si ça
nécessite des médicaments je fais aussi
des ordonnances sont patients réguliers
souffre depuis une huitaine de jours du
paludisme avec des poussées de fièvre
mais pas question pour lui d'aller à
l'hôpital plus cher et trop risqué selon
lui
il y a le coup il y a le coc vide
actuellement tout le monde est malade tu
as peur d'être contaminés il faut de
l'argent cette femme a failli mourir
après des soins à domicile qui ont mal
tourné
transporté d'urgence à l'hôpital elle a
pu être sauvée dès qu'il a fini je me
suis senti mal à la maison j'ai perdu
beaucoup de sang ce sont des gens qui
ont dû m'aider
si souvent après avoir tout tenté dans
l'informel que des malades arrivent dans
des structures sanitaires légal le plus
souvent un stade avancé de maladie
c'est un salaire total des patients que
je reçois ex sommes passés par msf
immobile je dirais 66 en quatre heures
et 70% des centres de santé privés
serait-il où selon les derniers chiffres
publiés par le ministère béninois de la
santé en 2018
et c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
jour n'a de l'afrique merci à tous ceux
qui nous ont suivis de cotonou à goma en
passant par abidjan rester avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]